I flew to Canada and they took my week
but not before I had been at the TSA in
Los Angeles you know and I always show
up the airport hi it's just so much more
fun to fly high you know and I like the
game like are they gonna catch me or not
so I'm at the x-ray in my bag and here's
what I didn't know now here's the thing
I always fly with almonds because a
couple years ago I get diagnosed
pre-diabetic and now I know nobody gets
high and is like oh where are the
almonds but it's [ __ ] where I am
right now yeah look if you have to get
high and look for unsalted cashews you
live my health you know so I'm at TSA
and almonds also when they go through
x-ray they kind of look like a mass they
take it out because they can't see
through it so they'll think it's a bomb
and they take it out the almonds were
near my edibles so they take out the
almonds and I know what's near the
almonds and she goes to put the almonds
back in the bag I'm like Bob I guess
that's it for me huh and she takes out
my bag that had like 20 animals and she
goes do you want to talk about these and
I said only if you do
and she said do you plan on taking these
on the plane and I said I'll eat them
all right now if you need me to I'm a
[ __ ] team player you know what I mean
I I've got a problem with eating them
all right now I'm gonna need a
wheelchair when I land I'm not gonna
know where the [ __ ] I am you're gonna
have to get my bags for me but uh but so
here we are
and so I flew up to Canada right and
they [ __ ] tricked me at the border
because they took my weed twice so the
first time I fly up to Calgary and I
brought edibles with me because in
Canada it's legal up there so I was like
no problem you know and so and again I
fly high and I land and the border
people in Canada are so much nicer they
trick you so I got off the plane and the
guy was like how you doing and I was
like pretty good and he was like how was
the flight I go was great and he was
grand I'm glad to hear it welcome to
Canada I was like thanks and he said do
you have anything you want to declare I
go wha
like what
and he goes what did you have any
cannabis or anything you'd like to
declare do you wanna Clara declare some
cannabis and he was so nice you know so
I was like sure he was so nice he was
asking he was so nice you know and he
goes what do you got I go I got three
edibles he goes is that it I go yeah and
he goes that shouldn't be a problem I
was like great and he goes just walk
down that hallway right there you should
be fine have a great weekend mr. wolf
and I was like hey thank you very high
in love Canada I walk into the back
they're so friendly back there - you're
[ __ ] waving to me I'm like hey you
know wanted me waving everybody
high-five with some people I sit down
with his dude and he's like how you
doing I go good he goes what are you
here for and I told him he goes man I
love comedy and he started tell me who
his favorite comics were and I was like
that's great man he was maybe I'll come
to see you show I go yeah he over some
tickets he goes I'd be great he goes I
understand you had some cannabis though
when I said yeah and he goes let me take
a look at it what do you got I go three
three edibles he goes yeah that
shouldn't be a problem now where I come
from where someone says that shouldn't
be a problem what that means is it
shouldn't be a [ __ ] prop right so I
put the animals down the counter and he
goes is it I go yeah any other all right
and he just slides him off the counter
in his hand he puts him in a drawer he
closes the drawer and then I said maybe
the stupidest thing I've ever said out
loud in my entire life I look at him and
I go but I declared those you know to me
like I thought I thought you know like
when your kid tells you the truth and he
still gets in trouble he's like I told
you the truth I'm like I don't got
[ __ ] care you're still in trouble so I
gotta declare those and the guy goes
yeah that's why I have him and I said
but like I thought it was legal here he
goes yeah but you can't fly with edibles
and I thought okay that means I can fly
with weed so two weeks later I'm flying
up again and this time I took my edible
on the plane because I [ __ ] learned
my lesson you know I'm saying come get
it now [ __ ]
I'll baby bird
if you want to but that is all you got
right so I eat the edible I'm high I get
off the plane
another very friendly person waving to
me oh my god she was super nice and she
goes how you doing I go great how are
you
she goes I'm doing great she was he
anything to declare any cannabis now I
thought I was good with I had rolled a
joint I'd put it in a sandwich bag and I
had wrapped it in a paper towel because
he said I couldn't fly with edibles that
doesn't mean weed right so I go yeah I
got one joint here she was like is that
it won't join I go yeah she was getting
any Elsi any food and I did I had some
almonds and I go to her I go I got some
almonds and yeah she got so serious she
goes how many bags and I was like I just
it's a two-hour flight like one bag like
I don't have enough saliva in my [ __ ]
body to eat two bags
almonds in a two-hour flight like I'll
back you know she goes how many almonds
in the bag I'm like yeah I didn't
[ __ ] ask for a 75 count of almonds I
I went to 7-Eleven I bought the bag and
now it's here and she goes let me see
the bag and I help it help and she goes
tip it upside down so I see there's no
holes in it I'm like what the [ __ ] is
going on up here never asked to see the
weed let's see the almonds like what is
happening right so I going back she goes
that it went back almonds one jointly go
yes she gonna should me a problem head
him back I hit him back right woman
behind the desk and she's really nice
too and she goes how are you I go great
how are you and she looks at the screen
this was so [ __ ] weird she looks at
the screen she goes I see you got
almonds
and I was like is there a [ __ ]
shortage up here like are you guys need
almonds I'd have brought a bag for
everybody I don't wanna I don't wanna
tease you with my almonds but yeah I got
a bag on home it's she goes how many
bags I go what one bag of almonds and
she was like is that it I go yeah she
was okay that's fine and then I said I
go do you want to see my joint and she
goes oh do you have cannabis I was like
[ __ ] they didn't even tell her they just
wanted her to look at the [ __ ]
almonds right and so she holds it in the
bag it's cuz it's in a paper towel and
she starts doing this and she's like she
goes what is that I said I said it's a
joint and she goes what is that just
like one big joint and I said well you
are holding it with two hands see when
the counter joint papa flies with you
know animate and she was great
she puts into the drawer and I go Bo I
thought I could fly I thought I could
fly with weed she goes who told you that
I was like you guys she goes he can't
fly with weed and you can't bring into
the country once you we want you to buy
it here I go just out of curiosity what
are you guys doing with it and she said
we put it in holding and I was like
right yeah yeah I know what that means I
had a cop who was a four I had a friend
who was a cop you know what holding
means that means if I mean when she goes
home tonight her roommates gonna be like
you holdin you know I [ __ ] am cuz I
asked her I go what do you do with that
[ __ ] and she goes we burned it I go well
I was gonna do this
[Music]
[Music]
you